every single business
on earth will have nft integration to
their business in 15 years the way that
every business has a website and social
media accounts that's not the moat how
you use the tool is the moat first of
all thanks for having me it's really
nice to be with all of you you know i
grew up i was born in the soviet union
and moved to the u.s when i was three
in 1978 i moved to new jersey in 1982
uh and grew up a really 1980s kid
on the east coast so i'm sure for
anybody who knows or enjoys the history
of toys r us you can imagine what that
meant it is for me one of the most
iconic brands it was such a tale
you know north star of my childhood we
were talking about jeffrey bucks
um outside
you know charles is an entrepreneur i
look up to because also on top of my
obsession with ip and storytelling and
pop culture and being very affected by
80s cartoons which were driving toy
sales
i grew up as a retailer you know i grew
up in a family liquor store business and
so i've always thought retail i've
always thought end caps like i remember
when he-man and transformers and cabbage
patch kids
hit toys r us and what that meant and
how they merchandised and teddy ruxpin
and like i took note even as a
everything that's happening with me
right now with the building of my ip on
the back of nfts
now seemed so apropos with the way that
i rolled
even even in my older age i sold my
entire sports card collection when i was
17 because i thought the market was
moving and spent four years only
investing and trading on collectible
toys so
living on geoffrey bucks starting
lineups and
you know action figures and all that
stuff so
a
profoundly interested in the
mascot-driven
entrepreneur in retail really you know
definitely one of those characters that
i know a lot about and admire how he did
it and how
the company did it
um and
i'm just really really humbled to be
with all of you today when we announced
the partnership together with macy's and
we have 13 executives from macy's here
in the room today the partnership that
macy's is going to roll out toys r us
inside every macy's store across the u.s
we actually didn't know each other at
the time
uh we met afterwards but unprompted you
posted a video on twitter and it has did
you mind if we play it
yeah okay if jessica you could cue it go
for it love the toys russ is coming back
as a sporting side of story macy's the
guy who read 400 locations this is a
classic example of like brand always
matters if macy's announced today that
they were putting toys in their stores
it wouldn't even hit like a press
release toys r us a store inside a store
people can't brand always matters how
somebody operates brand how they make a
contemporary how they execute that brand
is the variable but you can resurrect
any classic
it was unfiltered
tell us about that um
i'll tell you about that in a very
interesting way 14 years ago i started a
client service business
the president of the united states told
me he was disappointed in me when i did
mark zuckerberg told me he was
disappointed all my friends that knew me
that kind of had a sense of me at that
point in my life who thought i was on to
big things
did not
comprehend why i decided to start such a
stupid business
um what i knew
or what i thought i knew now i can say i
feel like i nailed it was
i sensed in 2007-89 that the only thing
that wasn't going to be commoditized
was brands and the ability to be a
contemporary marketer
and and at that point i just didn't have
any money you know i spent my entire
career building my dad's business for
him if any of you are in immigrant
family businesses
you know he'd always be like well you'll
get the business one day i'm like dad
you have great dna i'm gonna be [ __ ]
75 years old when that happens
so i had to start my own thing i wanted
to learn fortune 5000 land i knew
entrepreneur land i knew silicon valley
land i did not know fortune 500 land so
i decided to have the humility and the
patience to build a client service
business and work with four fortune 500
businesses but i always knew that i was
building an operating system i knew that
my agency would eventually turn insular
and be a reverse private equity machine
so instead of buying brands and cfoing
them i wanted to buy brands and cmo them
create hyper growth
and i've always thought about arbitrage
like this like what is out there that's
you know for whatever circumstances an
opportunity and how do you inject this
is to me the brilliance was it was
distribution in a moment's notice for me
the thing i spend the majority of my
time on is
you know i have 14 million followers on
tick tock because i got serious about it
when it was musically now that's a moat
for me to market but then it's also been
a mode for all the brands i work with
and as i build v-friends
i'm always looking for the art as a
matter of fact let's talk real really
about toys r us and toys for a second
i believe as a preview to i'm sure we'll
get to it i believe that nfts
right now
are the first thing i've seen since
after school television in the 80s as a
platform for ip building at this scale
if you think about 1981 to 1986 after
school television you're talking about
transformers thundercats he-man
strawberry shortcake care bears my
little pony all building through that
distribution channel the rebirth of gi
joe
it's profound if you think about that
window we've had for 30 years there's
been other pockets of ip building but
that many of significance it was a
moment in time where there was a lot of
attention on a specific distribution i
feel like nft land 99 of the nft ips
that we see right now are destined to go
to zero 99
and i'm talking about the ones that are
valuable right now because the operators
are young and not focused on ip
development but there will be 15
meaningful ips out of the tens of
thousands that i think will replicate
that era
and so i'm always looking for those
moments underpriced attention i call it
in marketing and
what i saw in that deal when i saw the
headline was underpriced arbitrage of
distribution against an ip that i
thought carried a lot more weight than a
lot of people might have
not recognized and so i thought it was a
masterful job on both ends how is vcon
what is vcon what will make as you just
said the ips that are real ip what will
make nfts work because believe me we're
thinking about nfts we've launched a
couple with toys r us we definitely want
to launch more we want to do it on
global scale we'd love to hear your
thoughts i think the first thing to
think about nfts and looking around this
room not everybody but a lot of the
people in this room lived through when
the internet hit as a professional
definitely when social media hit as a
professional
people are very good at underestimating
and over estimating things when they are
new
and so the same thing that happened with
web 1 and web 2 is going to happen with
web3 the
the
i remember when i launched an e-commerce
wine retail website in 1997 um
i remember in 98 99 2000 when i started
getting attention for it because we
became the largest independent wide
retailer in the country on.com people
would come up to me and say gary i've
got a website now and they thought that
was the win and i was like that's nice
like what are you gonna do with it
twitter and facebook for sure at that
point my career was in a different place
so many people would come up to me in
2007 and eight and say
i've got a twitter
as if that was the win uh same thing
with this just because you have an nft
every single business
on earth will have nft integration to
their business in 15 years the way that
every business has a website and social
media accounts that's not the moat how
you use the tool is the moat
and so
um that's how i think about that as far
as v con when i did v friends so v
friends
is an ip that i stood up last may
um
though it's uh 268 characters that
really focus on
the
attributes in the world that i'd most
admire patience kindness empathy i think
it's a mix of sesame street meets sweet
pickles if you remember that book series
with a little bit of like pokemon
and so i'm really excited about it i've
always wanted to buy an old ip i mean
literally three months before
i started v friends i had heard that
gumby was on the market and was like
gonna like look into it like that's how
much my brain's been in this world for
two decades and so
i stood that up for context of economics
we've done two series drops in 15 months
actually i'm sorry
what's today in in one year we've
13 months max yeah
12 and a half months we've done two
series drops we've done 100 million
dollars in revenue
and then more interestingly enough and
that's in nft revenue more interestingly
enough
and this is where this gets real serious
real fast
when you drop an nft
you get the royalties in perpetuity
so when i go find
like i did two years ago a thundercat at
a garage sale for a dollar in package
still ljn may they rest in peace
i
sell it on ebay for 280
and i
make all that margin ebay makes all that
margin fedex makes all that margin and
whoever owns ljn these days makes none
of it whoever owns thundercats makes
none of it
i v friends in 12 months has done 250
million dollars in secondary sales i
have three different series in play
i'm getting between 5.5 and 10 royalties
on every transaction
these are staggering economics on an
ebitda level if it trades in trades and
change that's how profound
royalties are d you know
i always say if george lucas was lucky
enough to have his timing down
because if you look at how thoughtful he
was when he made his kenner deal and why
he didn't make other deals
if he had done that
when nfts were happening let's say
destiny had nfts and the blockchain
happening in 76 and 77 there wouldn't be
anybody in a mile of his wealth
today and so
i think um
for everybody here
i mean you it's very rare to actually
have ip that matters
there's a lot to think through
now
the economics i just threw out are a
byproduct of timing
it you know there's a lot of grown-ups
in this room if you remember what
pets.com was valued at in 1999 on the
stock market
you know i knock on wood feel like i'll
be able to put my head on my pillow
because i'm going to spend the next four
decades executing this ip
um but if i was to launch be friends
today i would not be able to get the
economics i just threw out because the
market is already out of its gold rush
base which is actually a great thing
because there's a lot of scamming and a
lot of like gold rush d you know just
the mockery that's not fun with early
technology
but then but the royalty component stays
in place the ip building stays in place
as a matter of fact i will tell you
i can't find a logical reason why
anybody on earth wouldn't start an
intellectual property first as an nft to
establish
their economics
there's absolutely no sense to start an
ip as a book as a toy as a youtube video
as anything else as than an nft because
of the way the economics and the
royalties and the leverage work and so
it's going to be a big impact this show
everybody in it everybody in this
convention center right now is going to
be aggressively
affected by the consumer blockchain
because of what it means for royalties
and ownership and ip rights and if you
are sitting in this room knowing what
you do for a living even though you
might not be touching directly ip you're
going to be interacting with ipv in a
very aggressive way please don't read
the headlines
please don't have your opinion on nfts
based on one friend's opinion on it
please if you're in this room
please spend the 25 hours to understand
what the blockchain actually is what it
actually means how it's actually going
to impact because it's going to impact
everybody on earth gary but speaking of
gold rushes and then you mentioned
blockchain let's uh maybe segue from
nfts to crypto are you a buyer seller
bitcoin
i bought bitcoin in 2014.
so
as you can imagine i'm in a very unique
spot where my basis is so low
um
i think
cryptocurrency is in such a different
place than nfts
so for me
nfts come very natural based on some of
things i just said
cryptocurrencies put far more pressure
on governments than nfts do nfts are
going to be tax profit centers for
governments
bitcoin starts going after tender in a
real serious way when when emiratsayer
announces that it's now accepting
bitcoin you sort you know governments
only have so much control they have
control around the money and the bombs
and if you take the money away there's
only one thing left and so
i'm i haven't spent the intellectual
time on cryptocurrency that i have on
nfts i
i would hold bitcoin from me myself even
if i bought it today because i think
it's across the chasm as a brand
as far as every other cryptocurrency i
have besides ethereum and solana which i
need to buy nfts i spent no time on it
so when all week in the last couple
weeks when everyone's like what do you
think about luna i'm like i have no idea
you know i what i understand is why
people buy things
what are you doing in toys and
collectibles because as you mentioned in
europe you talked about some of your
kind of growing up and your roots uh
it's very well known that you were an
avid collector of a lot of things in
fact you mentioned jeffrey dollars i
believe you told us on the phone that
you have did you say 17. i think you
told us 17 000
i should definitely not tell this room
what i used to do with jeffrey dollars
well that could tell us the refund
policies were very different back in the
90s
um what are you doing so
so
once as you can imagine when you do 50
million dollars in sales in a week on 94
margin
you're like uh oh i've got a big tax
event i've got a big opportunity and so
for me v friends is going to be
vertically and horizontally integrated
the animation studio the toys all of it
comma i want to do lots of things with
other partners as well yes i want to
make my own plush i'm incredibly open to
mattel and hasbro and anybody else who
wants to have a conversation i want to
do jb's i want to own my own stuff
serendipity clicks in it's really fun
that they're here darren like you know i
met toy keto early on he was fundraising
darren told me about his background um
i've made the majority of my decisions
in my life around intuition
i made a substantial investment in his
company and i felt that i owned enough
of toy keto where i could do my core
business instead of just fully doing it
inside myself here with somebody who
really knows the business
i like i think is capable and so we're
doing
our toys right now with toy keto
but from day one from the first combo
i'm looking at him right now i said hey
i'm gonna probably do stuff with hasbro
mattel and squish mellows and moose toys
and like i need to you need to
understand how i think about the world i
think about the world as and as long as
you're very upfront
and over communicate
what your strategies are and who you are
i think there's a lot more and than orr
i'm thrilled to do an exclusive i'm
thrilled to do exclusive for a period of
time but i always want to be able to
have flexibility um and so
we've uh we got very serious about that
conversation and then obviously we got
connected and we got very serious about
our conversation
[Music]